[Musique]
tous les partenaires de la filière canne
sucre rhum énergie étaient réunies ce 13
juillet autour du préfet jacques billant
à la préfecture en présence de jean
françois carenco ministre déléguée à
l'outre-mer par visioconférence pour la
signature de la convention canne un
moment qualifié d'historique
aujourd'hui je suis donc
particulièrement heureux comme tous les
signataires de la convention est d'avoir
abouti à cet accord un accord qui nous
permet vraiment de consolider la filière
canne-sucre énergie rome à la réunion et
c'était bien l'objectif
le soutien monde agricole sera amplifiée
par le département compétent en matière
agricole et autorité de gestion du
feader qui prévoit d'attribuer aux
acteurs de la filière végétale dont la
canne à sucre une enveloppe de quatre
millions huit cent mille euros
le département a toujours été aux côtés
des planteurs bien sûr pour toutes les
filières agricoles mais on a aussi
montré dans le cadre de ces négociations
qu'on était capable d'avoir de la
réactivité et on a su mettre en place
cette enveloppe dans le cadre du plan de
résidence nationale pour aider la
filière végétale pour favoriser et
encourager l'achat des intrants on sait
que le coût de l'engrais a explosé à la
réunion et l'aide du département va
permettre d'accompagner les planteurs
dans la replantation mais également dans
la manière de retravailler leurs champs
pour la prochaine campagne sucrière 2022
on le sait va être une année difficile
en termes de résultats mais il faut
garder courage garder espoir la
convention et la mue des parements et
l'a également aux côtés des planteurs de
cannes pour faire en sorte console cette
filière
cette aide sera versée dans la tente de
soutien complémentaire attendu de l'état
pour une prise en charge globale des
surcoûts de production pour les
agriculteurs réunionnais dans le cadre
du plan de relance national
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]